muy pronto las altas temperaturas de
emiratos árabes Unidos no serán una
sentencia de muerte para las abejas
en esta región del planeta son comunes
temperaturas que llegan hasta los 50
grados Celsius uno de los tantos
escenarios que causan la muerte de
cientos de abejas al día aquí en medio
de las montañas de ata el centro de
descubrimiento y jardín de abejas de
miel desarrolla una innovadora propuesta
para fortalecer genéticamente a las
reinas de las colmenas y así alargar su
vida en medio de un ecosistema inhóspito
pudimos modificar algunas abejas para
que pudieran sobrevivir Al Calor de
emiratos árabes Unidos por medio de
manipulación genética pudimos elegir
ciertos genes en las abejas que permiten
que la abeja reina Viva en temperaturas
cálidas
según una investigación de la revista
Science de 2020 el aumento de la
frecuencia de las temperaturas que
excedieron los registros históricos fue
una de las causas directas de la
disminución de las especies de abejorros
a este problema se suma el uso de
pesticidas plagas y depredadores
el pájaro comedor de abejas migra de
Europa y viene aquí a comerse las abejas
un pájaro puede comerse unas 80 abejas
al día lo que hacemos Es ponerles ruidos
fuertes en los parlantes o sonidos de
águilas y Halcones para alejarlos de las
abejas
con iniciativas como las de este centro
los científicos buscan recordar la
importancia de estos insectos para el
funcionamiento del mundo mientras
trabajan para aumentar su población y
cuidarla de las amenazas diarias que
reciben de los ecosistemas cada vez más
complejos